[Music]
everybody welcome back to our city today
I'll be building between the city itself
and the airport which is an area that I
have filled in so far and I think it's a
very good area to try and experiment a
little bit with some new stuff so for
once I built the sunken highway a little
bit more about that later because it's a
bit of a weird thing for this series
really but also some experimentation
with the foliage to see how we can make
the transition between the city and it
does it happen and I'm also kind of
adding a small office district nearly
Airport since that felt like a good nice
conclusion to the airport area as well
so without further ado let's get into
the time s all right now I'm starting
off with these sunken highway since I
put that in the title so I might as well
make it the main thing here to be honest
I already built the highway itself in
the first episode of the airport I
believe so the highway itself isn't
something that I'll be working on but
it's mostly the detailing around it and
I think that's why this feels so weird
to the city in multiple aspects I've
always said that the city isn't really
about the detailing and it definitely
isn't about starting to build highways
everywhere and making a very typical
American or even a typical city skyline
City it's more about these planning
ideas behind the city and trying to just
experiment with how you can make the
city in the Gulf that's not as corny
payments as the current biggest cities
in the Gulf area are and this just kind
of goes against that the very idea of
having sunken highways in the middle of
cities as popular as they might be in
city skylines are wildly unpopular in
real life and it's not something that I
would realistically want to place in a
city like this but there are a few
reasons why I didn't want to do that one
of the is just that I wanted to I just
wanted to try this quite honestly I
I just wanted to see what it could look
like and experiment a little bit with
the detailing because frankly detailing
isn't too big of a focus in the series
either so it's I just felt like it would
be fun to try and mess around with this
but also because I felt
could realistically be a road bottleneck
since this is the road leading into the
rest of the city and I also didn't want
this to all just be at street levels and
trying to experiment with how you could
have this kind of sunken highway and see
how you could at least make it somewhat
livable and not completely to fight the
city because that's that's kind of the
main issue that you have where you're
building a sunken highway through the
middle of your city you're kind of
defining two different sides granted
that you don't have enough bridges and
it's also a big source of pollution at
least one that I know of and that's also
been an inspiration in this build is one
going through the middle of Rotterdam
where pollution was a big issue both
noise but also just general pollution of
the air but something that I thought was
very interesting and why I planted so
many trees alongside this one is that
adding the trees alongside that sunken
highway is something that's a bit of a
solution to both of these issues at the
very least it's something that cleans
the air quite a bit and in the case of
Armour City here should hopefully cool
it down a little bit as well so even
though we do have the sunken highway
going on here on that very main sort of
traffic nerve going into the rest of the
city I at least try to fill it up with
as much foliage as I could and make it
also as narrow as I could hence why
there aren't any streets on the sides
it's really just some sidewalks on the
side to at least make it hopefully as
livable Attica
then again I really just wanted to try
and make a song and highway like that
and the basically detailing is religious
some planters and trees along the sides
although I also have that main divider
with some fences and palm trees in the
middle the big thing here is that it's
kind of preventing this collision
between the Ring Road and the road going
into the city the only issue is that it
does mean that the connection of this
neighborhood that I'm working at the
moment to the rest of the world or the
rest of Bahrain I suppose is not quite
too good it's going to have to go
through the same intersection that the
Airport roads are going to have to get
through but for the rest of the city it
should cut through one intersection my
main issue that I was in the end not to
concern about was that I didn't want the
entry roundabout of the city to just be
spreading out from the highway I didn't
want to have like a highway that ends
with the roundabouts that's in the
middle of the city because it just means
that you can just speed up to the
roundabout and just keep speeding
through there
it's not exactly the kind of environment
where you'd want to drive slowly even
though I want to have people driving
slowly through that roundabout so there
is still an intersection before you go
into the roundabouts and I will still
put some traffic lights in there just to
make sure that people don't speed into
the rest of the city but yeah in general
I know that adding the sunken highway it
doesn't make all of the sense compared
to what I've been doing so far in the
city and how much have been focusing on
getting the cars out of the streets but
it's just something that I quite
honestly wanted to try a bit of a guilty
pleasure if you will now here I'm
working on the office districts and I
reckon that's a little bit more
interesting than just doing all of those
boring residential districts which we
have so many of already normally I don't
actually want to separate my sones
in the city too much so I'm saying
residential districts but there's just
quite a bit of general mixing of zones
throughout the city but this is very
strictly and clearly an office district
I reckon and I'm just trying to kind of
build a wall of buildings between the
airports and the rest of the city here
quite honestly which should hopefully
curb with some of the issues so maybe
noise that you might be having from that
I'm not too sure how much sense that
makes because technically there isn't
really a case where I think that's done
but I just figured it would be nice to
finish up this area like that and I
think it also just kind of have kind of
looks nice how this the surrounding sort
of higher density area
around the airport here and I'm quite
happy with how the of this district
turned out so far it's definitely still
a little bit of detailing to do
throughout this episode but the basic
layout is really just those couple of
buildings I'm quite happy with how that
sort of composition is and also I keep
building more of the Russian buildings
throughout the city they actually fit
very well for the general theme many of
them are still a bit too large for the
skillpa city but I found a few that
actually worked quite well so I put
those on the residential side things see
how we have quite a few tall buildings
around the edge of the airport here but
I'll be filling the rest of the
neighbourhood in pretty much in the same
way as we've been filling in the rest of
the city and this is this is one of the
things which is extremely time consuming
about the city so it's one of the things
that I hope to get done as quickly as I
can and one of the reasons why I may
make the city a little bit smaller than
my original blends were which means I'm
still going to add a couple of
neighborhoods but I'm not going to add
that many more I think it's already
quite sizable and I'm not going to go
with quite as many artificial islands to
the city as I was originally going for
simply because adding all of these these
neighborhoods like these basic
neighborhoods that we've seen quite a
few of inner city already it's just such
a standard thing then it's almost become
a sort of routine to do them and the
last thing that I want is anything that
I do in the game to start feeling like a
routine like not only is it just kind of
killing and not so fun anymore for
myself I just think it kind of kills
creativity as well and that said I also
just have some ideas that I really want
to have starts at some point in the
future and longer I'm working on our
city the longer it's going to take
before I can start on those other years
as a side note I don't think I've ever
talked about these individuals but I get
some comments about them my current idea
that I've been having for many months
now is to start the Japanese city
and another one is to start a new Dodge
City I know I've already had a new Dodge
City but I would love to get into some
modern touch planning but yeah those are
some ideas on my back burner that I'm
still downloading assets for and trying
to prepare for it but for the time being
we're in our city so yeah let's let's
get back to the present just wanted to
say that this is still some stuff that
you might be seeing at some point in the
future and some of the stuff why I don't
actually want to start spending too much
time on Armour City the main things that
I want to get into are really some of
the more interesting stuff like getting
to a university or hospital or healthy
solar panel fields outside the city
there's plenty of stuff to talk about
there for now here I am also finishing
of the office area the new asphalt
decals or or well but the mold in
general is super revolutionary and I'm
still extremely happy that we can
actually finally get some realistic
parking lots so that's something that
I'm extremely hyped about still and it
especially works for these sort of small
in-between areas where even though I'm
not exactly building american-style
parking lots of a grand scale it still
adds a lot to the area to be able to
just add these smaller parking lots with
actual asphalt and in a much more
realistic sense than you ever could with
the in-game sort of concrete parking
lots which basically make no sense the
only thing that was kind of difficult
about this area though is getting that
transition from the office area into the
rest of the city but I guess that's also
kind of a problem of having the rest of
the city be this close to the airport
it's it's honestly it's a very tight fit
right there
so as for all the street decoration and
this is this is one of the reasons why
these neighborhoods are kind of killing
because every building of course has to
be placed separately but also all of the
decals for the ground textures have to
be placed instead of just being able to
line them up like regular roads and all
of the planters and trees have to be
placed alongside the roads as well
it's just something that that ends up
taking a lot of time and the kind of
stuff that I kind of very secretly hope
I don't have to do too much in the
future anymore although I do have to say
playing with decals of course they turn
into one of the most revolutionary
things in City skylines
and it's kind of its kind of difficult
since there aren't too many desert
filling decals but there's still one of
the best things that I think have come
out of this game they do end up taking a
lot of time if you want to get into a
general sort of detail when it comes to
a city of this scale more pretty much
everything is hand placed so to get back
to the neighborhood that I'm actually
building here for a second I think this
is really one of the most European
neighborhoods of the city if that makes
any sense at least in the sense of how
its built up it obviously has that
European city district core mixed zoning
to it but it kind of has the has very
similar build up as in terms of what
kind of buildings are being put where as
well since there are really just five
six sometimes even seven floor tall
buildings around all the sides of the
roads and there are a couple of main
arteries which have some very heavy
traffic volumes but the rest are pretty
much these super blocks of somewhat sort
of mid sized buildings which is
something that you don't see throughout
the entire city like the downtown area
has that sort of part European part and
has the skyscraper area which doesn't
even feel to European center esque and
the rest of the city has row houses in
many places and it's a bit more like a
very tight fitting high-density suburb
but this is really one of the few parts
of the city which actually feels very
European to me in terms of how its
building at least around the sunken
highway right here it's actually got a
lot of very high density buildings I
will by the way at some lower density
areas I've already kind of talked about
the suburbs but I do get some questions
about whether I'm still going to build
those typical sort of proper Dubai esque
suburbs that's something that I'm most
likely going to Li how if not just
because there
aren't really any assets to do that it's
also because it's one of the things that
I'm trying to avoid in the city if
anything it's more inspired by the
sustainable cities of monster city
things like that except hopefully a
little bit more close to what cities in
real life actually are and I won't
really be getting into any sub urban
parts of the cities just because I feel
that's something you don't do in a
climate like this and especially with a
city that doesn't really work very well
for cars everything just has to be a
higher density than those suburbs and
their world definitely just be some
detached houses and there are some like
lower density areas with row houses but
everything still has to fit more so than
a large spread out sprawling suburb in a
more American sandwiches it is very
interesting
like how american-style those suburbs
are which you see are not Dubai and
areas like that it's something that I
might love to play around with but I
don't quite think I can do it in a great
way so I'd rather just focus on the idea
of this city as on and really it's it's
more so the layouts of the city down
look that I'm working toward then the
detailing on a small level even though
you see me doing the detailing all the
time in these episodes because that's
something that takes a very long time
what you don't really see is the way too
many hours that I put into like trial
and error seeing what kind of things I
would build where or making rough bad
sketches of how things should be going
which it which is all part of the fun
but it's something that doesn't
translate too well into time lapses now
back to the very small part which I'm
building here this actually turned out
to be one of my favorite parts of this
build I might actually turn this into
the thumbnail I'm not actually sure at
this point I know that I threw out a
picture of those parts on Twitter the
reason that I was very happy with this
area is because it's it's a somewhat
densely foliage area but it still has
send everywhere and
it was my first sort of little
experiment with making a park-like area
looks somewhat nice without having to
blunt grass everywhere a reason why I
kind of felt that was relevant to say is
because there's just no realistic way
that you're going to have grass turfs in
an area like this it's definitely
something that's popular in the by and
if you want to do it in your home I
think it's actually pretty cool but
something like large parks with very
large spread out areas of grass turf is
something that I don't think I'd quite
want to add to the city because it's
very unsustainable so my parks are going
to have to be much more assembly and
close to what nature would actually look
like in moraine and some of the clients
who I actually does have greenery so
that that was one part of the
experimentation but also somebody
commented on the last episode and there
was a very good point
I should be adding some foliage and
basic vegetation around the city and run
the roads because otherwise there's just
going to be scent whipping up everywhere
and I believe I've seen there's actually
quite a few times going around the area
of Dubai on Google Streetview where you
can actually surprisingly go quite far
into the desert and it's always very
interesting to see those kinds of areas
but there are definitely some areas far
out there where the grass always just
kind of sweeps over the highways and
over the roads and that's something I
definitely wouldn't want to have in the
middle of the city I do so a bit of a
foliage is hopefully going to be barrier
to contract that the thing about foliage
in a city like this is that it pretty
much it pretty much always has positives
like the more trees you have in a city
generally the better it is unless you go
trees over buildings or something like
that but basically trees are generally a
pretty good thing like they look good
they kind of clean the air they make and
they make everything cool down a little
bit but the thing is there's one big
downside for a city like this like this
and that is that three state law of
water and especially in a climate like
this where it's barely
water per year and what it does I
believe it does get it in pretty heavy
rain storms which iron which are only in
one part of the year so it's not quite
something that I can bank on and most of
the water in moraine I think at least in
areas like this is still coming from
underground but that's getting saltier
by every passing year and part of it
also just comes from desalination plants
which isn't too big of an issue but you
know want to start taking too much water
that you could be using to give people
water to drink for trees it's just
simply something that is either
unsustainable because it takes a lot of
energy to turn salt water into into I
keep saying sweet water because I'm
Dutch but yeah it takes a lot of energy
to turn salt water into fresh water but
also there is just no feasible way to
take that much water from the ground
where water levels are going to just
start drops and the more the groundwater
gets saltier the worse it's going to be
for the foliage around the area and I
believe that it's just a reinforcing
cycle of the water quality in the ground
getting worse and worse there is plenty
of water in the Gulf actually but it's
something that's being overused at the
moment as far as I know besides I do
still want to get into some experiments
of bolting trees in in the deserts and
stuff which is something that's a very
interesting sort of recent development
but yeah I'm stunning to speak nerd here
in Urdu basically I'm trying to add some
extra suburbs around this area and there
was the last thing that I ended up doing
in this part of the video we're getting
toward the outskirts of the city here
and I really think these houses right
here are just going to sit pretty much
against the desert so yeah this is this
is really getting to the outskirts and I
also wanted to get to a bit of a lower
density around here and just kind of
build off from the high density moon of
the city toward a few of those row
houses on the edges here so we're
slightly building down to
lower densities and building these
neighborhoods and the biggest amount of
time here really goes into planting all
of these trees and adding all of the
planters and stuff like that so I'll be
cutting ahead a little bit through this
time lapse and going back to where stuff
gets interesting again because I ended
up this episode by putting a little park
in the middle of the neighborhood
although I kind of did that off-screen
and also adding some more foliage around
the outskirts here and I continued that
off-screen as well but I'll show it up a
little bit in the cinematic shot so you
can have an idea of what it looks like
in the end and for now at least this is
kind of my prototype combination of
foliage and decals and scenery to
hopefully make that transition into the
desert work for now though it's really
just the transition from the city into
the airport and the look of the
outskirts of the city as it's going to
look for now so yeah thank you guys for
watching I hope you enjoyed and I'll see
you all next time
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
in there
[Music]